It is gradually become clear to me what
every Greek philosophy up until now has
consisted of namely the concession of
its originator and the species of
involuntary and unconscious
autobiography.
Well,
that's deceptive.
That's the deceptively simple sentence.
Even though it's not a particularly
simple sentence because it stands on its
head.
What people generally assume about the
process of thinking.
You generally think that when you're
thinking,
you're thinking about,
as I mentioned before,
the structure of the objective world
need is making an entirely different
point here and what he's fundamentally
doing is treating the philosopher not as
a rational being,
but as a living being,
and there's a big difference between
being a rational being and being a
living being.
Because if you're living being your
primary goal is to do whatever it is
that furthers your life and if you're a
rational being,
then your primary goal is to do whatever
it is that a rational being.
Mike Do,
and you could say that a living being
should first and foremost be a rational
being and in some sense that's the
message of the of the Western
enlightenment.
But it's by no means self evident that
that's the case and it's certainly not
something that Nietzsche Nietzsche,
who doesn't believe that people are
rational beings,
certainly not primarily,
and more importantly,
he isn't exactly convinced that they
should be so.
So for example,
one of niches,
most famous maximums is that truth
serves life and that's a very difficult
different idea.
Then the purpose of truth ses,
the accurate representation of the
objective world.
Those aren't the same thing at all.
Now you could ask,
well,
what does it mean for truth to serve
life?
And if you construe truth that way,
what would truly look like?
And you know the mere statement that
truths should serve life doesn't offer
you the answers to those questions,
but
what did?
It's the beginning of a different
metaphysics and in some sense of
metaphysics,
which is say the universe within which a
philosopher might operate a metaphysics
is the initial structure of
presuppositions within which a view of
the world is organized.
One presupposition might be human beings
are rational and that we're attempting
to formulate and improve our sense of
the objective world,
our formulation for the objective world,
and another would be that you would be
aren't rational or irrational and that
we're.
What we're motivated to do is to live
whatever that means and that the purpose
of our thinking and our philosophy
should be to facilitate our living.
And that's niches.
That's one of the foundation
blocks of philosophy.
So He's a moral philosopher
fundamentally because morality is about
values and the values.
Essentially values are
you could say values are what you aim
for,
but it's more complicated than that.
Values actually constitute the lens
through which you view the world.
So it's partly what you're aiming at,
but it's also partly your conception of
who you are now and where you are.
And it's also partly your conception of
how you're going to get to where it is
that you want to be.
And it's also partly the psychological
system that you use to parse up the
world so that it reveals to you the
pathway that you could take to get to
what you want,
values,
all of that,
and then it's more than that because you
could say that you have added value
which contains all of that,
but then you can say that you have a set
of values which is the arrangement of
all of that out,
and then you could say that you have a
set of values that's the range,
but of all that,
that you have to arrange with other
people and then you could say that you
have all that and you have to arrange it
with other people and you have to
arrange it across different spans of
time because what you want today and
what you want next week and what you
want next month are not necessarily the
same thing and one does not necessarily
lead into the other.
So to be a moral philosopher is to
examine how that,
what that system is and how it operates
and how it came about.
Now,
one of the things that need to says is
it has gradually become clear to me what
every Greek philosophy up until now is
consisted of namely the confession of
its originator and the species of
involuntary and unconscious
autobiography.
So his claim fundamentally is that no
matter what the philosopher thinks he's
doing well,
he's reading philosophy.
What he's actually doing is revealing
and articulating his being,
and then you might say,
well,
where did that come from?
And the answer to that is,
well,
partly it's you could consider it a
biological function.
In so far as that we have value
structures that are built into us that
are the process.
We would say the process of a very long
evolutionary history,
but because you're also a cultural
phenomena and because the manner in
which you've arranged your values and
your desires has been conditioned to the
last degree by the process of
enculturation that you were subjected to
when you
confessed and an autobiographical manner
and articulate that what you're also
doing is really capitulating the entire
structure of your culture.
It's in you and you might say,
well,
where is it in you?
In that and what does it you mean,
part of it means is that you act out a
pattern of behavior and that pattern of
behavior is like a dance that someone is
manifesting to a symphonic score.
It's unbelievably complicated and it has
its psychological elements and some of
those are conscious and some of them
aren't.
Some of them are just implicit,
embedded in the way you act and the way
you perceive and what the philosopher is
attempting to do is to reveal those to
himself and to articulate them so that
the entire structure can be analyzed
well.
So niches.
First proposition is that when a
philosopher is thinking that what he's
doing is not thinking,
it's revealing himself and an
autobiographical sense under the guise
of rational thinking and so then it
becomes something more like a story and
well,
any covers all that in the first two
phrases.
So that gives you some example,
some indication of what this book is
like.